hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
now this one is gonna start out with one
called Roth I don't know why I'm
clapping pretty Boppity boo boo boo boo
this one's called rot and it looks
fantastic it looks so good I actually
had to go into my game settings or my
card sent my computer I had to use my
Wizarding magic to zap my computer into
something that could actually record and
handle this game at the same time I
don't know why and I don't know what
this game is about but we're gonna find
out right now I'm actually don't even
know if there's a straight-up horror
game oh hi well I already have a problem
here because I'm starting this out in
the middle seat and I don't know who
volunteered for the middle seat um
somebody gonna get that don't mine do I
need to get that do I need to do
anything about that
guess I'll just be here then boys lovely
oh I need to press a button about it oh
okay so I needed to press a button
well I did that oh it's me oh good I
didn't volunteer to be in the middle oh
that's my arm okay that man my hand is a
few a few inches too far forward from my
face and just able to turn right a
little too much but let's boo-boo it's a
horror game
oh no oh hi um Oh I'll be right there
I'm sorry I'm not sorry I didn't know
that weird but I want to help trying to
help also I'm wondering if I should
trust there's something off to my left
[Music]
here there's no case
it's okay ah that's gonna hurt you
Oh my webcam froze well that's weird why
did that happen and why did it freeze on
that face well hang on hey hon I go oh
[ __ ]
Oh am i back ok I'm back now I don't
know why froze or when but died froze
again why what the [ __ ] - [ __ ] is what
why is it happening stop happening stop
it
Oh No is you gonna freeze again face oh
you gotta freeze all this time my home
base got one oh jeez oh it's gonna keep
hello hi hello how are you yes I'm still
there okay listen I owe my phone ah my
face is frozen God [ __ ] a duck this
isn't my camera's fault this time this
is oh this is something else entirely
why are you doing this are we back we're
gonna stay back
okay I'm watching me okay alright so
this is bizarre
I don't know this is this game [ __ ]
with me over there's something else
[ __ ] with me but I'm being dict with
and I've got my eye on it I'm really
looking at it okay you still out there
it's got paranoid sidelong glances now
in this game play and not for the
reasons that I want to have it okay so
she's not hello
Oh design why is there a flashy do I
want to know what the flashy is well I
want to know at all
[Applause]
[Music]
what is that about what is that about
oh my god oh wait hang on that's amazing
it looks really good Bernardo know
what's happening oh oh dear Lord is
there like a tornado behind on the turn
of a god tornado hit it didn't I need to
get indoors I need to be indoors why
went the wrong way around I gotta go the
other way around the house my camera and
froze it's just gonna freeze in the
wrong faces Oh
I don't think the Sun works like that or
is it something new
Mississippi steps are those oh my god
Oh like oh my god whoa hey mom hey wait
wait whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa I
can't one hey hey
oh boy what's your phone why I don't
know what's happening oh oh hi hello how
are you
good to see you uh-huh I'll be right
with you I'm very busy this is my
favorite video yeah uh-huh I'll put that
right up to my ear hole something's
wrong with me I need some help
[ __ ]
I owe you and I
okay I guess that happened whatever that
was I don't even know what I saw well
what happened did I shoot at somebody or
did somebody shoot at me that's what I
couldn't tell okay all right - good god
I don't know why this game is funky with
my graphics but it's really cool it's
like it is making me panic that I don't
know if that's making the experience
better or worse yeah Oh dumb Chum Chum
tells me that was a bad idea to grab
whatever I grabbed unlike for any item
like three
oh good a gun oh oh my god oh that's so
cool I don't think the Sun works like
that what the [ __ ] is happening oh my
god
lady wherever you are I don't remember
something tells me I'm not gonna be able
to get in that house back to your
village you don't have to tell me twice
I know exactly where I'm supposed to be
in what fight it's like I'm back I mean
it hurts uncles I don't know why she's
owning anyway somebody was there
something was there something something
was there in the passenger seat Oh
something still there I really
baby baby no baby whoa baby no baby I
see a light I'm gonna go towards that
blindly cuz that feels like a good thing
to do anyway done love the crunching
that's one of my favorite sounds to have
it right in my ear
the crunching definitely something that
I'm gonna cherish along with the baby
crying like these are just good sounds
across the board
yeah Danny wait so how are you you good
okay I'm good here oh hey we made it to
the lights good oh it's another oh oh I
froze again well it was only a matter of
time
[Music]
ha ha ha all right we're back I don't
know what this is doing I feel like now
it's just in tension oh it's the same
car nevermind
[Music]
[Applause]
baby forget again again with this [ __ ]
there I am [ __ ] what happened cuz I of
course is gonna [ __ ] happen when my
dim plane one of the coolest horror
games I've played in a long time and
he's gonna [ __ ] with me it froze again
I'll try I'm dry real hard let's go go
and if it freezes again I'll fix it and
that's just what I'll deal with and if
it freezes in the middle something is
wrong this way okay back here do I need
to go back here Oh
okay it seems nice like a trouble glad
you started the light show back up
that's awfully comforting
[Music]
oh well good I'm just back here
everything's hunky Hecker bubble Zee
cookery oh that's so cool it sounds so
cool
based on wrought by corridor digital
wait wait what dafuq corridor digital
made a horror short what the [ __ ]
check out our other games on of course
I'll check out your other games that was
so cool
what the [ __ ] those I don't even know
that what that was awesome it was rad
that was rad dude wait hang on now I
gotta check out something hang on I
gotta check this out and I don't know
why my webcam was doing all that [ __ ]
but man that was cool okay so they've
got they've got two other games
one of them's called the evilest horror
game ever which might be a joke just
judging by the name and then they've got
one of them which seems to be a more
serious venture so I'm not actually
gonna try both of these games and see
what happens
this is the evilest horror game the
evilest horror game ever made
nice farlis dudas the story is based
this story based game features player
choice the consequences of all your
in-game actions and decisions will
impact the future choose wisely okay I
will based on a true story man I'm
almost positive that last game my panic
in it was 90 percents because I had no
idea you death sin evil murder please
kill soul psycho Oh can't read that
oh you death sin okay same thing I don't
know why I'm here or what I'm supposed
to be doing this in association with
Archie
maybe it's not a joke okay I'm sensing a
theme in these games
hey hey Sammy gonna handsome devil mean
car dealership why does it look like big
guy
Assassin's Creed who goes into his past
oh wait no yeah I'm definitely sensing a
theme in some of these games
the evilest story okay but still just
with that kind of title it just kind of
suggests to me that maybe it's not so
much
nice
so everything started several years ago
it was the first of March 2010 a man
went into a hotel and asked to see me
the boss
when I came the most terrifying story
began his room 39 empty yes yes sir
confirm of course you can thank you
before going through the room the client
asked me to provide him with a black
knife 39 centimeter white threat and a
73 brown orange I agreed though I was
surprised at the way thanks the client
asked to have and client went into his
room he didn't ask for food or anything
else
okay unfortunately for me my room was
next to room 39 what is this what is
this there's like Resident Evil One ask
camera angles oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
I'm so into this now give me that [ __ ]
give me that [ __ ] scare me scare me baby
scare me oh god I need to think about
this old ass backwards oh geez all right
come on I'm ready for it
Oh they blew all the budget on the
cinematic angles they can't go any
further about it oh my god this is so
cool yo he's so stupid this is probably
like an April Fool's joke or something
but good to god this is so silly
it's like oh I'm sorry
my bad I forgot the washing machine is
here oh no open ah I opened it
[Music]
oh he take picked up hotel door keys
okay all right here we go
Oh
hotel door codes I don't want to write
those down oh wait hey are they gone I
was gonna take a picture
ah [ __ ] well [ __ ] I can't please go to
sleep e dot dot dot on the bed huh
please don't pull your pants at midnight
I heard strange voices and noise in that
clients room voices of wild animals and
utensils and dishes being thrown on the
floor hey Lord come on with the noises
come on now be considerate be kind
rewind oh [ __ ]
don't work there was some codes here
let's see if I can go back and get those
I don't know how seriously to take the
morning when the client handed me the
keys I asked to see the room first how
does it sound like someone's taking a
dump
Oh someone's saying a dump
that's very clearly someone taking a
poopy open all right what's going on in
here all right come on
found everything all right nothing
unusual I even found a threat the Black
Knight with you know Rachel Dean table
okay no what has four letters sometimes
nine levers but never has five letters
what what is four letters sometimes nine
letters a mailbox dude I don't know the
client paid the bill and gave the
bellboys a very good tip and left the
hotel smiling I was in a shock but I
didn't reveal what I had to the bellboys
in fact I started to doubt myself
one year later after one year the client
showed up again asked to see me again I
was in a puzzle me t is room 39 empty
yes yes sir
can i book it of course you can go for
it
thank you the client asked with the same
Thanks
room 39 black 939 centimeter white
thread and a 73 gram orange this time I
wanted to know the true by all means
possible
I spent a sleepless night waiting for
something to happen
the midnight the same voices and voices
started this time louder and more
indecipherable individual paper no three
plus nine equals 12 9 minus 3 equals 6 6
minus 1 it was 5 to plus 5 equals 25
all right thanks I guess
what is it what is this what did I what
did I take I don't know what I took what
did I take what is what is what is this
what is this what is I don't know I
don't even know I'd rather get my webcam
like cut out I don't know what's
happening is this just intentionally
meant to confuse me I'm starting to
think this is intentionally meant to
confuse me I know that was not clue [ __ ]
hey again before leaving the client paid
his bill left a large tip on the table
for the bellboys the smile didn't leave
his face I started searching for the
mink of everything the client asked to
have why did he ask from 39 white the
white thread what the black knife I
don't know I didn't arrive to any
convincing answers to all these
questions
I was now eagerly waiting for the month
of March the month in which the client
showed up oh my god if this is the game
where it just loops back and forth over
and oh my surprise on the first day of
March the same client showed up he's
room 39 empty it's it's gonna be the
same thing over and yes sir it's gonna
be the same thing over and over again
can i book it
of course you can thank you you ask the
same questions wanted to boot the same
room wanted to have this things like
access before ok and head this way
noises this side more louder than usual
there is something who can catch but
can't throw I don't think it has an
answer I think it's just all nonsense
whoa ok maybe not
because you keep it down in there their
neighbor there's like the demonic
sacrifices ain't to chill Val lab
well okay see you never have a good'n
you sleep sleep tight in there in the
morning when the client was leaving the
hotel
I apologize politely to him ask to know
the secret behind the noises in the room
if I tell you the secret do you promise
to never reveal it to anyone else
of course promise I promise I will never
let anyone know swear I swear it I swear
I won't review your secret
and you know what until now I haven't
revealed this secret to anyone you but I
sworn him so I won't sell it to anybody
maybe someday I will let you know thank
you for playing party wasting my time
you [ __ ] just why would you even do
this I knew it was all [ __ ] I knew
it was now I knew it was God it wouldn't
have mattered you could have put all
those goats in it wouldn't have mattered
ah [ __ ] yo borscht ya [ __ ] horse of
course it was a big waste I knew was a
waste of my time even when I was
starting to play the goddamn game but
then there I was still playing it [ __ ]
why all right damn you alright so this
game is also made by these guys but it's
serious one of them which isn't the
usual chant that I like to scream at the
top of my lungs
why Navas is what I like so if we can
get back to more me and not them at the
grave then they will go away to eternal
punishment
but the righteous still turn so you
suggesting to me that I'm not going to
eternal life I'm going to the the
opposite the whole eternal punishment
thing is there what you're suggesting
[Music]
oh I gotta pull that out okay here we go
fun day at the the knife removal okay
I'm really trying to yank it oh ah
that was bad thing oh I guess [ __ ] [ __ ]
me all right hi okay well that was fun
delightful glad I did that I'm never
gonna do that again okay I think that's
just the end of the oh it's is the end
of the hallway I thought I saw like
something there like a face or something
okay all right
some tells me that was a bad idea
hey I'm holding my side when you talked
about the sounds from Hell tonight
my uncle had told me this story a couple
of years ago and I didn't believe them
like one of your listeners who
discounted the story is nothing more
than just a religious newspaper
fabricated again
the story about the digging hearing of
the sounds from hell is very real it did
occur in Siberia cause very hesitant
send you this as the sound bothers me to
listen to I'd suggest that if you do
play it on the program warn listeners in
advance so they may have the option of
turning the radio off for 30 seconds
while it plays it has always wanted me
it is true and I for one wish it wasn't
and so I submit now they cleaned a
better copy to you and I warn you what
you are about to hear is very disturbing
indeed
[Applause]
you could stop at any time now I feel
like that was
in 30 seconds
nobody's gonna go I realize that I don't
actually have to I probably don't have
to listen to that I don't know why I did
talk about setting the mood Oh
hard pass on that one big Mambo Jambo
okay we're going in it's dark to me I
nice tuchus whatever you're by me you
think you can play these games with me
you cannot okay yeah all right
you in there still buddy huh yeah that's
right try it again try me again you
catch these hands you dick with me let
the last game you get dick it with and
turn hi
[Music]
Oh someone playing the bongos in there
hi hello how are you doing oh nice
either pecks or boobs I don't know what
I'm looking at but your eyes are the
most captivating of all hey how's it
going okay
[Music]
Hey okay uh what the fire hey wha wait
oh uh okay
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
okay we're all good then
okay yay that was fun
glad I went down there to turn on a
radio I really like chewing up this
place is power bill I can't open that
one good this looks vaguely familiar but
I think it's just the layout because a
lot of these unity games reuse
prefabricated like air but I've never
played this game before one thing that
these guys made this do well is sound
I've always said sound is 90% of our
games
okay well this place is brightly lit
cheerful fire
why did I come here
why didn't I run away I had the
opportunity literally there's no worse
place that I could have gone right here
right now I look another brightly lit
room okay
the Popo
what the hell you doing down here
well that radio didn't really do much I
guess I'll just listen did you do that
hey come on now just before you start
Twinkle Twinkle in you're gonna go oil
like that start singing a tune I
actually like you take it away from you
right at the last second is that a
spookin chair it's a smoking chair hi
you debate and sitting in this Buchinger
nice tuchus
[Music]
why am i moving everything's going to
white I'm assuming that's a good thing
[Music]
welcome to the game okay I guess I
joined your little cult here no don't
look at me no no no that don'ts agree it
makes sense no holy [ __ ]
that was awesome that was awesome
it was really well done got these guys
see it was like I think it was a
prefabricated level that I've seen
before in another horror game but that
other horror game didn't do it as well
as this game did it this game did it
great this game did a wonderful job with
it the ambience the spookiness it showed
a little bit too much of the monster
like right off the bat I think I think
it was good he led me into places I
didn't want to go gave me a sense of
dread that I haven't felt in a long time
and it was a good thing setting it up
with that audio thing of like the sounds
of Hell like that bad that audio drama
that that came from it was super super
well done cuz it said just like this
tone for the whole thing oh my god
that's crazy and even the opening like
going into that pulling a knife out
right out of the bat it was like totally
disconcerting right off the bat good
stuff so anyway that was one of them and
that was three scary game
April Fool's one who's pretty good
but these the it book ended with these
great ones and I like how it was only
that first game was messing with my
camera I think he might have been even
doing it intentionally at this point
because it was like what the [ __ ] I was
in such a panic and it was actually kind
of cool oh good and we got that going on
now but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to play
any of these games I'll put them in the
link in the description below and if you
want to help support the channel click
the join button you get a lot of special
perks there's already a backlog of
member-only videos that you can check
out through the community tab thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]